Good morning, Hank, it's Tuesday.
I don't know what today's video is about.
I'm on a social media hiatus right now, it
turns out it's very difficult for me to hiate
from social media, but I'm on the hiatus to
write a book.
Like, I've been "working" on a novel for the
last four years, but I'm trying to, like,
take the quotation marks out of that "working".
But like, when I'm really into a story, it's
hard to think about anything else, so I'm
just, like, sitting here thinking about things
that I can't tell you about.
Anyway, I think it's going well, but who knows,
I've been wrong before.
I know there were things I was supposed to
talk about.
Oh, right, NerdCon!
Hank, NerdCon: Stories is just like a week
and a half away in the beautiful city of Minneapolis.
There's a great bunch of storytellers coming,
but the relevant thing here, Hank, is that
somehow or another, I agreed to a race car
race with my friend, Maggie.
You know, Maggie Stevater.
Stivater?
Stream Water?
You know, Maggie, who wrote all of those great
books.
Apparently, it's Stiefvater, Steve like the
name, otter like the mammal.
So separate from NerdCon, she and I are going
to be racing in actual race cars on an actual
race car track on October 9th at 7:30 at Princeton
Speedway outside of Minneapolis.
It's 5 bucks at the door, all the proceeds
go to this charity Drivers Edge, and I have
to wear, like, a helmet and a fire suit in
case my car catches on fire, and I'm going
to lose.
Oh, also, there's flowing water on Mars occasionally,
apparently, and it's very exciting, and the
SciShow people got so excited, they made,
like, shirts and posters.
Hank, I feel vicariously very happy for you
whenever there's big Mars news like this,
but you what's so exciting that we haven't
taken a second to just be psyched about lately?
Flowing water on Earth!
Earth, man!
What a planet!
Sarah says I should show you how my tattoo
is doing, so I'm going to do that now.
Don't get alarmed, Hank.
I'm just, you know, taking off my shirt.
Still there a little bit.
What else?
Oh!
The wall!
So many people, Hank, were complaining about
the blank, blue wall that I finally put up
my wall stuff.
We've got Woody Guthrie and his guitar, a
big Willy and a medium-sized me and a puppy-sized
elephant, this weird card someone sent me
of Hank humping Peeps, these Yoshitomo Nara
figures were edited by Sarah for my birthday
back in 2007.
And speaking of the Yeti, there's one, as
well as a misprinted business card, and Brotherhood
2.0 resident mathematician Daniel Biss's original
paper about how circles are really just bloated
triangles.
I was just thinking that a lot of this seems
really weird if you haven't watched every
Vlogbrothers video, but then it occurred to
me that it also seems weird if you have.
"I heart my Nerdfighting Peeps", and then
of course we've got the Swindon Town F.A.
Cup Championship from 2011, Abraham Lincoln,
a black Santa, a road map with Agloe, New
York on it, the beer sword, beautiful drawing
of Willy, Nerdfightastic shoes, Chewbacca,
a DFTBA ducky, and An Imperial Affliction,
which I stole from the movie set.
Then we've got some Willies, and puppy-sized
elephants, and French llamas, and St. Francis
of Assisi.
I'm not really sure what he's doing there.
It's just a start, Hank, but I think it looks
pretty good.
Nerdfighters, let me know what I'm missing
in comments.
So, Hank, I was just violating my social media
hiatus by looking at Twitter to see if there's
anything else I should talk about, and as
it turns out that in the last hour you've
launched a new company.
Hank, you amaze me.
That's not a compliment, exactly.
It's just an observation.
So, Hank, DFTBA Games, which you co-founded,
has just launched a Kickstarter for its first
game, Wizard School.
It's a card game that hones one's wizard education
skills while one waits for one's letter from
Hogwarts which one hasn't totally given up
on, even though one is technically 38 years
old.
I, for one, am excited.
In fact, I was one of your first ten backers.
The Yeti and I are huge nerds for tabletop
card games, Hank, so this is very exciting
for us.
OK, Hank, I'm going to go back to working
on the story now.
Hopefully, I'll be able to report real progress
on a real book soon.
Hank, I will see you on Friday.